on va demander au public de rester dans
un endroit précis pendant environ un
quart d'heure 20 minutes et d'essayer de
résoudre une énigme pour avoir le droit
de sortir du bâtiment et d'aller
découvrir le reste de la ferme ou
d'aller faire une autre énigme dans un
autre bâtiment donc moi je suis ici
parce que la vergère elle m'a appelé
quand elle est arrivée ce matin elle a
remarqué qu'il y avait un mouton qui
avait mangé tout le grain qu' avait dans
le S donc il faut absolument que je le
retrouve parce que il va avoir mal au
ventre très bientôt il faut que je le so
et que je le mette dans l'infirmerie
derrière chaque jeu a la a son sa petite
histoire on a essayé de rendre vivant un
petit peu ses énigme donc par exemple au
niveau de la basse-cour ça va être
l'aviculteur qui va s'êre cogner la tête
et qui a oublié le nom de son coq donc
les enfants doivent retrouver le nom du
coq pour l'animation des
chevaux on va avoir des charades les
enfants devront trouver les réponses aux
charades euh tout ça mise en forme sous
forme d'une interosurprise d'un
professeur euh toutes les réponses au
charad sont bien entendu en rapport avec
les chevaux au niveau des vaches ça va
être Dona notre chien à la ferme qui a
mangé le cahier d'un élève il a qui l'a
déchirer il va falloir rassembler un
petit peu tous les morceaux du cahier
pour trouver la réponse à l'énigme et au
niveau des moutons c'est un mouton qui a
mangé un saut de grain il va falloir
retrouver quel est ce
mouton chaque étape innocente un mouton
et à la fin on a le coupable et c'est le
vétérinaire qui veut savoir lequel pour
pas pour voir lequel va être malade on
était plutôt sur un thème de Circet
carnaval pendant les vacances de février
on a voulu changer et plus axer sur un
thème qui se rapporte à la ferme des
fois faut même regarder sous les poules
d'accord des fois il faut soulever des
fois il faut chercher dans les graines
et cetera d'accord là on a surtout accès
les les escape games sur les métiers
donc on a un jeu au niveau des chevaux
avec le métier du cocher un jeu au
niveau des vaches au niveau des moutons
et au niveau des poules toujours en
mettant en avant un petit peu le
l'agriculture biologique et et
l'agroécologie plein de petits bouts
comme ça qu'elle a mis partout dans le
bâtiment donc il va falloir m'aider si
vous voulez bien à retrouver tous les
petits morceaux de mon cahier c'est un
peu novateur on va les seuls en en ferme
pédagogique et dans la région un peu à
tester ça euh on va on va espérer comme
à chaque vacance entre 300 et 400
personnes par jour ce serait bien on va
dire que c'est dessiné à peu près aux
enfants de 4 à 10 ans donc tous les
après-midis ça commencera à 14h30 la le
dernier on va dire départ d'escape game
euh se fait à 16h euh le cinéjeu c'est
une séance à 15h15 une séance à 16h15 la
carermè ce sera en Contin continu tout
au long de l'après-midi et puis à 16h30
on peut retrouver comme d'habitude de la
traite des vaches et 17h les son aux
animaux à la basse-cour ce qu'on leur
apprend c'est comment être responsable
dans l'environnement et comment bien
agir dans le dans la nature et dans la
vie en règle générale l'objectif c'est
de venir et de d'apprendre en s'amusant
puisqu'il y a toujours quand même un peu
d'apprentissage sur chaque métier et
puis surtout de le travail un petit peu
en équipe puisque là les enfants je
pense seront aidés de leurs parents ou
de leurs grands-parents enfin des
accompagnateurs qui seront avec eux et
puis ça permet de s'amuser en
famille